what's going on everyone it is your
buddy josh back
again with another comedy video i'm at
my
new studio here in nashville i told you
once i got to nashville nothing would
change so you know
just hanging out in the fur coat just
ready to get things started but i want
to talk to you today
guys about raycon earbuds you know
how much i like these things not just
because the sound is amazing
not just because they are like half the
price from those other brands
not just because they
look great but man you know the other
problem is
those other earbuds they fall out of my
ear we all have different holes
raycon makes earbuds that fit your hole
some holes are big some are small some
are deep
some are shallow some are wide it's like
a dr seuss book everybody
but raycon has the buds to fit
your hole now as if me
saying they're great wasn't enough guys
snoop dogg
wears them and you know snoop dogg and i
hear things
the same exact way these are
wireless earbuds that
rock your world they have a 45-day
return
policy come on everybody let me tell you
something they started half the price
they sound amazing it makes a great
holiday gift because you're going to use
them every day because you don't want to
listen to your
family you just want to hear the stuff
you want to hear
on top of that everybody now is the time
to get these best prices so make sure
you hurry
this offer is available for a limited
amount of time click the link
where i'm fingering you in the
description box you're going to get 20
off your raycon purchases guys six hours
of play time not the two hour
not the three hour full cross country
flight
get the best discount of the year on rey
counts
raycons now through the end of november
go to
byraycon dot com slash josh wolf to get
20
off your order by raycon dot com slash
josh wolfe to get 20 off your order
guys don't you want something to fit
your hole
happy holidays i recently
you know my wife and i finally i finally
took her to do something that i haven't
taken her to do in probably a decade
i i refuse to go to uh romantic comedies
and i i'll tell you why because they're
not they're not for us
they really truly aren't written for us
there's not it's not for us
it's it is a wish fulfillment for women
and for guys that say you need to do
some more of that
but the truth is the stuff that that
we're supposed to do doesn't work in
real life it only works in the movies
so that's why look my wife you can't
walk out of those movies feeling good
about yourself
but my wife walks out of those movies
like
i love that movie
and i walk out of those movies like man
[ __ ] matthew mcconaughey he makes us
look bad guys because he does things in
movies that work in movies that don't
work in real life
i saw one movie he was having sex with
this girl in the shower he was tearing
it up
yeah man that [ __ ] looked sexy and soapy
and i was like oh yeah
i'm gonna try that and i went home and i
tried it and i was like that was
terrible
because sex in the shower is the worst
place in your house you can have sex
your feet are slipping all over the
place and she was like stop pushing me i
i'm [ __ ] speed skating behind you
right now what
you're pulling me down i'm actually
doing physical activity
in two inches of water on a slippery
surface
you're lucky we're not both [ __ ] dead
right now you know and then in the
movies her boobs look so good
pushed up against the glass door right
try that at your house
the door just goes
and they make first time sex look
amazing it isn't amazing because we
don't know each other's bodies
awkward things happen when you have
first-time sex not in the movies
nothing awkward happens when matthew
mcconaughey and sandra bullock have sex
when matthew mcconaughey and sandra
bullock have sex they never make that
awkward noise when their
stomach slapped together you know you
know when you're [ __ ] somebody and
it's like
did you just fart on me i am not sure
i'll go check uh
and that dude has endless energy doesn't
he like he'll have sex with a girl up
against the wall
then he'll pick her up and he'll high
knee it over to a different part
then i'll have sex with her here and
then he'll spin her around his finger
for a little while
i'm matthew mcconaughey i do crossfit
[ __ ] yeah
that is not real life real life
10 minutes into sex with my wife and i'm
like babe you
i've got to get on top
why you think i'm beautiful up here no i
am [ __ ] winded do some work
[ __ ] this is a two-man game get your
heart rate up man let's go
and that dude doesn't sweat he glistens
even sweat from head to toe that is not
how we sweat when we're on top of you
when we're on top of you
there's that one disgusting drop of
sweat hanging off our noses
oh we see your faces you're like no no
every woman in here has dodged a [ __ ]
sweat drop to the mouth before you're
like
[Applause]
and that's why i won't take her to those
movies
it's not good for my sex life you know
what is good for my sex life
hotel sex
guys if you don't know whoever you're
having sex with at your house
turns into somebody completely different
at the hotel
at the house you're like hey hey hey you
want to have sex
just washed these sheets
you ask later like hey you wanna have
sex well
i just ate a bunch of potatoes
with your vagina or
but you get her to the hotel and she's
like punch me in the face what
now go wipe your dick on the curtains on
the curtains
just anywhere on the curtains or
i gotta tell you i feel like i know guys
pretty well
there's like 100 chance there is a guy
in here right now going
huh
i've never wiped my dick on a curtain
before
there's a pretty good chance somebody in
here wipes his dick on a curtain tonight
and if you do
just tweet me that's all i'm saying
hashtag dick on curtains and go ahead
and send that my way
but on our system honor system i don't
need a picture of some dude like this
[Music]
[Music]
you